Britain's Prime Minister has returned to
work firing to lead from the front in
the fight against coronavirus Boris
Johnson was diagnosed with the virus a
month ago and spent three days in
intensive care in his first speech since
leaving hospital he says the UK is
starting to turn the tide in tackling
the outbreak Johnson's pledged his
government will outline plans for easing
restrictions but he's warning of the
risk of a second wave John hallwas
joining us live from Westminster in
central London Jonah the tone of the
prime minister's message was very much a
rallying call what's he been saying yes
a rallying call trying to bring the
public with him trying to display a new
sort of sense of openness in the face of
persistent criticisms in his absence
both of his and his government's
handling of this crisis well Britain has
its Prime Minister back
he left ICU intensive care two weeks ago
remember suffering from kovat 19 the
disease having come fairly close by his
own admission to taking his own life
he's now back at number 10 Downing
Street back at work and facing a complex
set of issues that he's got to deal with
first of all those criticisms of course
also persistent shortages of PPE
personal protective equipment for people
on the frontline the health care
community the care community medical
workers and so on and also testing
nowhere near the government targets set
for the end of this month and that will
need to be ramped up vastly if it's to
deal with that much feared second wave
but perhaps the most crucial issue and
the first thing on his in-tray is these
are these calls these louder and louder
calls for clarity for a way forward on
this lockdown Britain entering its fifth
week of restrictive measures now calls
coming from far and wide about how it
will be eased when it will be eased what
are the measures that will need to be
put in place in order for the lockdown
to be eased and Boris Johnson having to
find a new tone a new form of language
learning to communicate with the public
to make sure that he brings them along
with him and the government now in what
is to come and that I think began in the
last hour or two outside Downing Street
with those words with that speech he
highly
did the positive first of all in this
the greatest challenge he said six since
the Second World War he talked about
real progress being made the NHS the
health service here not in fact being
overwhelmed as many had feared he talked
about the beginning of the country
turning the tide but he said to those
desperately looking for signs that the
lockdown was going to be eased anytime
soon now he said he's not the time
because of the fear of a second wave a
second spike that he said could be even
more disastrous for the country and for
the economy contain your impatience he
said as we reach the end of the first
phase of this conflict here's what he
had to say if this virus were a physical
assailant an unexpected and invisible
mugger which I can tell you from
personal experience it is then this is
the moment when we have begun together
to wrestle it to the floor I know it is
tough and I want to get this economy
moving as fast as I can but I refuse to
throw away all the effort and the
sacrifice of the British people and to
risk a second major outbreak and huge
loss of life and the overwhelming of the
NHS jonne these are obviously very
strong words from the Prime Minister
but the hard work begins now doesn't it
because we're still faced with a UK in a
very very difficult situation
well the UK has reached its peak of the
epidemic according to the scientific
community that peak was hit some time in
the first around the first week of April
but it hasn't seen the rapid declined
that many might have hoped for it is
still passing through the peak that
declined that has happened in terms of
new infections hospital admissions and
so on has been disappointingly slow
according to the scientific community
and the great worry is that if you ease
these restrictions now and there are
signs that the public are beginning to
get restless with the nature of this
lockdown in particularly the sort of
vacuum of information weather that many
perceive to be going on here not knowing
quite what it is any longer that they're
working towards quite what benchmarks to
be set quite what they need to be
looking for on the horizon well as that
restlessness continues the worry will be
that people unilaterally start breaking
the lockdown and the scientific
community's concern is that if they do
that now the system simply are not in
place to prepare to guard against to
control a second wave testing is only
now beginning to be ramped up it was
only last week that the government
announced plans concrete plans for
testing contact testing and contact
tracing which is the vital sort of
mechanism that needs to be in place in
order to control that second wave and
prevent another enormous death toll so
they're not in a position to ease the
lockdown the public want them to ease
the lockdown this is a massive problem
for the government it's something Boris
Johnson is going to have to tackle
head-on and he will have to tackle it it
more than anything else perhaps with
soothing reassuring language that allows
people to believe that he's back in
control that he is taking this as
seriously as it can possibly be taken
and that all the measures that need to
be taken are being put in place that
update from Joe Nahal life arose in
Westminster in London German thanks very
much indeed well the Prime Minister's
made no mention of the various
criticisms of him and his government the
ones that Jonah was mentioning to recap
medics across the country say supplies
of personal protective equipment or PPE
has been insufficient the target of a
hundred thousand tests per day has not
been met Britain actually tested fewer
than 20
9,000 people in the past day as
concerned the death toll is likely to be
far higher government numbers refer only
to hospital deaths but do not include
deaths in the community and in care
homes coronavirus has now claimed more
than twenty thousand seven hundred lives
in UK hospitals with more than a hundred
and fifty two thousand confirmed cases
my good fellows a political journalist
and she's an author and she's joining us
now from London thanks very much indeed
for being with us
Jonah there was saying that it is up to
the Prime Minister to present a very
strong and firm grip on the country but
do you think that's going to be enough
to satisfy his critics no I think
there's actually a major problem here
there is a big disconnect between Boris
Johnson's tone but also the content of
his speech and what is actually
happening in the UK so he talks about
people looking at the UK and in apparent
success in relation to coronavirus but
actually we has at the moment have one
of the words death rates in the world
as you've said and 20,000 more than
20,000 deaths in hospital and that
figure seems to be much higher if you
take into account debts in the community
and deaths in Cairns and new these are
not just figures on a sheet these are
human beings these are people across the
country who would have lost their family
their loved ones and will be mourning
for them and it's very moment and I
think it's quite insulting the Boris
Johnson to take this tone to not mention
PPE shortages to not mention the crisis
mashup social care system to not even
engage with where there may not be any
failures in these criticisms of
government and what I'd also say is he
used this analogy of the virus being
something like a physical assailant he
talked about is being this invisible and
unexpected mugger and as well as really
disliking this kind of match of language
that I find quite unhelpful it's also
inaccurate this was not unexpected
insofar as the UK had a bigger lead time
than many other countries in the world
more time to prepare for this and it
seems that government has not done that
has not followed w-h-o advice in terms
of testing tracing and then isolating
and you know for a lot of public workers
frontline workers whether that may be
people
supermarket and it just up care workers
people working in our schools it is
upsetting I think to hear the Prime
Minister talk like this as if their
experiences in their day-to-day isn't
happening at all and I would say that
it's only a few weeks ago that Abdul
Chaudhary and NHS doctor was desperately
pleading for PPE and then died from
coronavirus there is a big disconnect
here but here between how the Prime
Minister is talking and what's actually
happening and I think the government
needs to engage with these criticisms
not just for criticism sake but to learn
from it and to respond to those places
early on in this in the spread of this
virus in the UK the approval rating for
the government and for Boris Johnson was
actually fairly high people were fairly
pleased with the way they were handling
this given everything that's happened
subsequently how do you think this is
going to play out politically for
Johnson when eventually the virus does
become under control I think so far some
of the opinion polls is one The Observer
newspaper yesterday that suggested
actually people's confidence in the
government had massively decreased and I
think as people get to grips with the
ins and outs of what has happened here
there will be some serious questions to
ask about government not least because
hundreds of thousands of people across
the country are being affected by this
in one way or another but also there are
some key things that they haven't done
and that they remain really quiet on
despite being us by campaigners and by
other politicians about what they're
doing so for instance in the area of
immigration enforcement
they haven't suspended the hostile
environment although migrants are able
to use the NHS if they're suspected of
having coronavirus symptoms and we are
all going to be charged in any way the
hostile environment has kind of seeped
into our public services and to what it
means many people the fact that it's
still in play is that they're scared to
access health care so we hear a report
the people who are migrants are dying
from coronavirus after having been too
scared to seek medical advice and
there's a serious question to ask about
the government's handling of this I
think will continue to be asked in the
coming weeks and I don't think should be
overlooked the fear of seeming to
politicize this actually I think there
are a big questions to be asked and I
think many members of the public
I'm gonna want to have those questions
answered my a good fellow we appreciate
you taking the time to join us on al
Jazeera thank you very much indeed